a new report recommends changes to
police training in Phoenix Arizona after
the city had the most officer-involved
shootings in the country 2018 was the
most violent year on record for Phoenix
Police with 44 police shootings that's
more than double the number in 2017 by
comparison the New York City Police
Department the largest in the nation had
just 17 officer-involved shootings last
year Jeff Pegues spoke with the Phoenix
Police Chief who commissioned the study
of her own department after she saw a
troubling increase in the use of deadly
force as any other city experienced 44
no yeah trust me now Phoenix Police
Chief Jerry Williams is battling the
perception that our officers are too
eager to use force after her department
had the most officer-involved shootings
in the country there are some people who
think well our Phoenix Police
trigger-happy there are some people who
think a lot of things my agency is
unafraid of the truth if there's
something we can learn let's learn it
let's fix it a new National Police
Foundation report says there is no one
issue they caused the spike in
officer-involved shootings in Phoenix
but notes assaults on officers were
higher than past years and more of the
subjects involved were armed Phoenix
based activists Greek Powter in action
says the Phoenix Police Department has a
history of aggression and issued a
travel advisory for minorities last year
in response to police violence in the
city we had a vigil here right after it
happened
Paris Wallace works with poder in action
she told us about one shooting last year
involving 34 year old Robbie Brown who
was shot and killed by police responding
to a call at a bus terminal he was
sitting at one of the benches and
somebody said that they saw him playing
with playing with a gun
Arizona is an open carry state which
means it's legal to carry a gun in plain
sight
but at least one witness said she did
not see brown with a gun at the station
and that he appeared to be listening to
music they ended up boarding the bus and
shooting him in front of over 30 people
say Brown ignored commands to drop his
weapon and produced a handgun from his
pocket when they confronted him the
national report also points to an
increase in use of force incidents with
no guns involved body cam footage shows
the immediate aftermath of a Phoenix
police officers scuffle with a blind man
named Marco Zapata in a gas station
bathroom last June you were approaching
the urinal yeah I didn't hear anybody so
he comes and turns around and he say I
think get up for me and push me really
hard and that's when I started defending
[Music]
him look at my eyes I'm blind
what did he say yeah Cepeda was charged
with aggravated assault
he spent 24 hours in jail but the
charges were ultimately dismissed you've
seen that tape I've not seen the tape
tape I may or may not I've seen the tape
we can we can I am NOT going to discuss
it as a paid a case one it's still an
active an open investigation into I
believe we are in litigation with it do
you get annoyed by those types of
questions when those incidents happen
I'm not going to say annoyed anytime
something like that happens it's
troubling you have to think about policy
procedures practices helping oversee
that effort is commander Jennifer
LaRoque she runs a new training program
at the Phoenix Police Academy what is
implicit bias which includes implicit
bias courses and de-escalation training
scenarios like these the old military
style where we come in and we start
screaming at people that's not happening
here anymore we've changed that up we
need to get back to the basic skills of
how to take someone into custody without
considering using the tool belt as a
first resort or if one of those fails do
we necessarily have to pull out our gun
and use deadly force
what do you think is the most important
thing in bridging the gap between
community and police it's about trust
can we always work on trust absolutely
can we always work on communication
absolutely and my agency is doing that
for CBS this morning Jeff Pegues Phoenix
the National Police Foundation report
notes Phoenix Police have already made
significant changes to their training
programs but there is no evidence yet
that implicit bias training or
de-escalation training will result in
fewer officer-involved shootings
you see those the footage there the the
cameras from the police officers there
was a time when there was a debate
whether that was gonna exist and you see
how helpful it is helping with this
training be more helpful if they would
look at the tape - I think that's
important that you at least got a look
at the tape I appreciate the fact that
Phoenix has acknowledged that they have
a problem they want to do something
about it and they're working on that a
very important story they certainly feel
the heat